4 ancien skinhead comparaissent depuis
ce matin devant le tribunal
correctionnel de marseille
ils ont reconnu être les auteurs de la
profanation du cimetière juif de
carpentras était temps en 1990 valérie
un mythe
philips la madeleine germain avait 80
ans lorsque la tombe de son mari félix
fut profanée et sans corps exhumés cela
fait maintenant presque sept ans que
madeleine germond attend ce moment là
tout à l'heure j'étais angoissé
maintenant ça va mieux
vous appréhendez des voix
les voir exacte des prévenus madeleine
germond ne verra que leur dos jean sweat
shirt baskets
seule leur coupe de cheveux encore très
courte pour trois d'entre eux rappelle
ce qu'ils furent des skinheads
c'est yannick garnier qui le premier a
pris la parole tout comme ce 31 juillet
1996 lorsqu'il s'était présenté
spontanément à la police pour se
dénoncer
nous formions un groupe dit il fasciné
par l'ordre établi l'apologie de la race
blanche
l'antisémitisme et la haine de
l'étranger oui nous adhérions à la
politique d'adolphe hitler mais j'ai
complètement changé ajoute-t-il
à l'époque j'étais embrigader lorsque le
président lui a posé la question de
savoir ce qu'était le troisième reich il
a répondu c'est le système qui a été
créée par le point de suspension par
adolf hitler
j'ai le sentiment que le führer est
resté dans son esprit guerrier part et
en fait la seule sincérité qui l'est
c'est d'essayer de faire table rase du
passé comme l'a dit le président est de
pouvoir offrir à sa future famille un
visage plus respectable yannick bernier
dit pourtant être fiers aujourd'hui
fière d'avoir parlé fier d'avoir des
regrets et aux autres jeunes qui
seraient un jour tenté de faire comme
lui il y as le temps je leur dirai
répond-t-il qu'il faut qu'il revienne
dans le monde des vivants de lui garder
y en sus pour nous ce procès alors
dominique une particularité
ce procès intervient tout de même sept
ans après les faits oui ce qui fait
qu'on navigue aujourd'hui entre des
autoportraits de nazillons repentis des
prises de conscience à voix haute et ne
hier il se déclare tolérant j'était un
lâche influençable le front national a
parasité mes pensées déclare l'un des
prévenus
il ya donc une volonté de minimiser une
volonté aussi d'assumer un acte qui au
moment des fêtes est considérée pour eux
je cite une grosse bêtise
donc effectivement le temps joue pour
eux il leur permet de se présenter
aujourd'hui sous un jour un peu plus
humain on aimeriez que ce ne soient pas
simplement un système de défense or
dominique on se souvient des
conséquences médiatiques est énorme de
ceux de sète ce pas faire mais
qu'encourent les
est ce qu'ils sont aujourd'hui jugés
quelles sont les peines encourues pour
ce type de délit oui vous l'avez dit la
profanation carpentras et l émotion le
dégoût d'une communauté d'une classe
politique de tout un peuple c'est aussi
six ans de dérapage judiciaire
médiatique
c'est aussi six ans de rumeurs de
manipulations et bien la réponse
aujourd'hui judiciaire semble en
décalage par rapport à cette émotion et
ceux des goûts puisque le code pénal ne
prévoit une peine maximum de deux ans de
prison ce qui veut dire aussi que dans
tous les cas de figure les prévenus
condamnés à moins qu'ils soient
évidemment relaxer mais en cas de
condamnation il serait de toute façon
libérée dans l'année qui vient
merci dominique